racing has lost one of the biggest names
in the sports history even if you don't
know very much about horse racing this
is a name of a former champion jockey
that can't have escaped you leicester
piggett was one of the greats and
incredibly sad news to bring you ahead
of the epsom derby that starts next week
he has died at the age of 86. this is a
man that broke records his statistics
are staggering during a career of almost
half a century he rode nearly four and a
half thousand winners and won the derby
a remarkable nine times he first won it
when he was a teenager
back in 1954 he was crowned champion
jockey 11 times between 1960 and 1982
and last year he rightly earned his
place in the british champions series
hall of fame now he came from a family
of racing racing was very much in his
blood and won his first race at the age
of 12 and quickly became a teenage
sensation
before then propelling himself during
his professional career to really become
a national hero this is someone that was
frequently pictured with the queen and
the queen's mother too during many of
those trophy presentations he would have
attended but he did have this massive
fall from grace when he was jailed for a
year for tax offenses and that led to
him being stripped of his obe but he
never really lost the affection of the
public before he retired of course in
1995. now lester we know had been
spending
time in hospital in switzerland and his
family say that he has died peacefully
there but a huge loss to the riding
community someone who was widely
regarded as one of the greatest riders
of all time lester pigott has died at
the age of 86.